it's like the confidence game of the
economic world is this gonna be the same
thing in the society as well part of
this I think is not only the facts or
the information but it's also the way
it's covered you know yesterday you you
had the tweet about the idea of all the
mainstream media kind of going away from
a presidential conference and obviously
super controversial is like what was
being said in all of that but just on a
more broad scale how do you think that
the media has been doing and covering
some of this stuff and like what are
they doing well or where do you wish
they would improve I mean I I try not to
look at the tell TV news anymore or the
cable news because there's just all doom
and gloom great and I don't think that
really serves any purpose you know
particularly since the audience for
traditional television is older right
when you look at the average viewing age
for CNN and Fox and MSNBC it's 60 plus
right and so those are the people who
are terrified anyways because of all
this because they're saying an element
when you look at the ratings and you
know the number of people 49 and under
there are 25,000 of them watching any
given any given show so they're
terrifying people who are already
terrified and so I think that's a
problem I think we need to start talking
more about what are you gonna do on the
other side right how are you gonna bring
back your business or what are you as a
consumer going to do one of the things
you're looking forward to buying so that
we have an indication that you know what
we will get through this there is a
better way to do things and there's
gonna be some exciting things that we
learn because all like we talked about
capitalism but there's gonna be a lot of
things that we realized it wasn't right
before let's let's do a better way or
there's gonna be lots of young
entrepreneurs that say I got this right
this is my vision they may be a 12 year
old or maybe they're a 60 year old but
there's gonna be new visions let's talk
to them and let's scare some of those
new visions and then in terms of online
it just kind of replicates you know
Twitter's Twitter right everybody's
gonna go nuts on Twitter but you know
online new sources are the same way
here's what's wrong here's what this
person did wrong here's what that person
did wrong you never see anything about
what people did right except for dr.
Falchi right and dr. Burks they're all
heroes and they that's deservedly so
and the frontline healthcare workers
their heroes and deservedly so but let's
get some things
let's start talking about America 2.0
let's start talking about how we get
through it like some of the things you
and I are talking about are more macro
but there's going to be a lot of things
a lot of people that have specific
visions let's get them out there and
talking and getting feedback you know
cuz that's that could be around the
corner a month for now two months from
now you know we're not gonna just do
things all the same way let's come up
with a vision let's get fired up right
there's so I want to talk to those
entrepreneurs I want to hear about those
entrepreneurs I want to see what new
products or services I want to hear
about those visions because goddammit if
we went through all this [ __ ] I want it
to be for something right and that I
think that's what they miss if we went
through all of this let's make it for
something all those people who died all
those people who suffered let's make it
so that wasn't in vain let's turn this
into something that makes this country
better yeah and it goes back to the
whole idea of the American spirit right
you keep talking about my kind of the
opportunity coming out of this it we
know that in Prior crisis's there's been
great businesses that been built or kind
of early days in those crises what are
you seeing as those opportunities you
kind of mesh in healthcare or their
other industries outside of healthcare
and AI that you think are gonna be big
or you all you see some of your team's
now saying hey look this is actually
where we think that vision is oh my god
so I had this guy company meepo and the
EPO who created new kinds of food so he
put could took the nutrients of a salmon
dinner with sweet potatoes and put it
into a cube that they're manufacturing
right now they're at the co-packer
that's 340 calories and it costs two
bucks to make right so when people are
when we get caught with shortages or
people are afraid to go out to eat the
you know or still if we get a resurgence
right and people really order people
can't get out of the house or kids are
not in school and can't get fed you can
get these things cheap and they have
more nutrients than trying to eat you
know a PowerBar type thing right or a
protein bar so there's you know that's
one example um how are we gonna you know
how are we gonna have fun you know so
you know right over here you can't see
it I've got these two bubble soccer
balls right and so we're talking about
how can we bring all the kids together
if they bring their own bubble soccer
ball by definition you know their social
distancing right
and they could just get out there and we
trade our own little local instead of
you know that the local baseball or
football or basketball league we're
gonna play bubble soccer you just get
your own bubble soccer ball just little
I mean it's silly in some respects but
those are types of things that
accommodate the new normal right that
allow people to try to get back to
having some normalcy and you know those
are two areas that just came out on that
field right create a team or do creative
things yeah there's so many more but
that you talk about the media let's hear
about that yeah right every every new
show should have at least one segment
what about this right America 2.0 what
about that right why not well and I
think the data suggests right there's
much academic studies one the positive
news actually goes more viral than the
negative news and then on top of that
one of the things I saw was if you wake
up in the morning and read three
positive headlines you're more likely to
say you had a good day at the end than
if you woke up and read three negative
headlines
so exactly we're not giving anybody
anything you know yeah this is not about
survival I mean look we're gonna get
through this with this is not a
situation where we're saying oh my god
there's no medicine coming we're arguing
about which medicine will work better
you know we're arguing about the best
way to deal with people are sick and
it's horrific you know that we can't get
it to everybody it's horrific that we
don't don't have the right solution for
every scenario yet but I think everybody
would agree that progress is being made
and that we're confident that we'll get
through it and because of that there can
be good news right and there can be a
vision for the other you know when we
get to the other side of this but we're
not hearing any of that at all except
from you of course yes